une mère une soeur une fille nièce 1186
femmes autochtones sont disparus depuis
30 ans au-delà des chiffres
nos collègues de la sivici ont voulu
donner un nom et un visage à ces femmes
230 cas non résolus ont été identifiées
jusqu'à maintenant et plus d'une
centaine de familles ont accepté de
répondre à leurs sondages et la note
qu'elle attribue aux policiers de
partout au pays et bien basse les
détails avec frédéric arnaud quelques
braises qui crépite pour ne jamais
oublier sa fille assassinée brutalement
à calgary en avril 2002
l' enquête policière sur le meurtre de
thierry anne dauphine et qui avait trois
jeunes enfants n'est toujours pas treize
ans plus tard mener à une arrestation
les enquêteurs sont nuls 10 ou martin il
ne rappelle jamais un sentiment partagé
par plus d'une centaine de membres de
familles ou de proches touchés de plein
fouet par 230 cas de disparitions et de
meurtres non élucidés compilées par cib
ici selon les témoignages de ces
familles le travail des policiers
étaient plus que faible leur attribuant
même une cote moyenne de 2,8 sur 10 cet
ancien enquêteur de la grc reconnaît que
les dossiers de femmes autochtones ne
sont pas souvent prise au sérieux en
colombie britannique par exemple depuis
2006 25 millions de dollars ont été
dépensés pour enquêter sur 18
disparitions
un seul dossier a mené à des accusations
une telle dépense avec peu de résultats
dans le secteur privé dit rémy charles
qu aurait conduit au licenciement des
enquêteurs lors de l' enquête sur la
disparition de deux autochtones
québécoise
emmanuel valter a aussi constaté ce
désarroi et cette déception dans les
témoignages qu'il a recueillis pour son
livre les survoler des familles vont
dire ma fille a disparu et les policiers
vont répondre est allé faire une passe
ou alors qu'elle est même pas prostituée
par exemple donc effectivement moi je
veux pas généraliser parce qu'il ya
certainement des policiers qui font bien
leur travail il ya des familles
autochtones qui se sont sentis tout à
fait encadrés par des policiers mais
a beaucoup trop de familles à qui on a
renvoyé comme ça des stéréotypes à la
figure au nom de sa fille et des
centaines d'autres disparus sous volté
une demande encore et toujours la
commission d' enquête nationale
qu'ottawa refuse encore et toujours ici
frédéric arnould radio canada vancouver